good morning good afternoon and good
evening everyone
thank you for joining us and welcome to
what's new and what's next for
networking
i'm shalish shukla vice president and
general manager for networking
and i'm wendy carty director of outbound
product management
we had a very busy year and we're so
excited to share what we've been working
on
we have a packed session
and will cover our cloud networking
portfolio
what's new in networking network
security and monitoring
but first
the why of networking
in addition to being a critical part of
the global cloud infrastructure
networking also drives real business
outcomes for our customers
as workloads and workforces become
increasingly global and increasingly
distributed
the network is at the front and center
of connecting securing and enabling
everything while delivering a seamless
experience to all applications all users
and all devices
for example our retail customers tell us
that a high performance network is
directly tied to superior user
experience which translates to faster
revenue conversion that's the top line
i don't want to go through each of these
items here but what you'll see is our
customers tell us in all verticals
across the world that networking is a
key enabler for their business
outcomes our cloud networking vision is
centered on our customers and the vision
is this
planet scale networking for a smart and
connected world
google has built a massive planet scale
network infrastructure
serving billions of users today
and we are leveraging advanced ai
automation and programmability to build
a self-driving network that makes it
simple
smart
trusted and open so our customers can
focus on running and enabling their
business
our global network is at your service
with 27 regions 82 zones
146 edge pops
thousands of edge nodes
16 subsea cable investments connecting
more than 200 countries and territories
worldwide
we are proud to serve billions of users
while staying 100 carbon neutral since
2007 and we continue to invest heavily
in our infrastructure our network and
just this year we have already added
four new cloud regions warsaw delhi
melbourne and toronto in addition we
have announced five subsea cables
echo firmino
blue
raman and apricot
which connect all parts of the world
from asia europe africa middle east to
the americas
on top of this
massive global network we offer a broad
portfolio of network and security
services that connect secure scale
optimize and modernize your network and
your infrastructure
to do that we have a full stack of
networking services from layer 1 to
layer 7 that provide high performance
networking for all your workloads
running in vms in containers or on bare
metal 2021 has been an incredibly
exciting year for us
we added several new products this year
including the google distributed cloud
cloud idea service
and enhanced our service networking
portfolio with network connectivity
center private service connect network
intelligence center enhancements etc
wendy will tell you a lot more about it
let's get started wendy over to you all
right thank you salish we have a lot of
exciting announcements so let's take a
look at what's new in networking
i would like to introduce our google
distributed cloud strategy which
provides a fully managed integrated
hardware and software solution that
extends google cloud's infrastructure
and services to edge locations and
customers data center
our distributed cloud solution is
enabled by anthos
through a centralized control plane so
customers can build and run modern
applications anywhere with low latency
and operational efficiency
google distributed cloud is ideal for
local data processing low latency edge
compute workloads modernizing on-prem
environments running sensitive workloads
to meet sovereignty requirements and
offering private 5g lte solutions for
enterprise customers
it can be deployed at google edge
operator edge customer edge and or
customer data centers
we announced network connectivity center
or ncc a few months ago and it is now
generally available
ncc provides a simple and consistent
management model to connect your on-prem
and cloud networking needs seamlessly
with ncc you can connect vpns partner
and dedicated interconnects sd-wans and
third-party router appliances in a
hub-and-spoke model and we've partnered
with sd-wan leaders like cisco fortinet
palo alto networks versa and vmware
enabling you to simplify connectivity
from branch to cloud
in addition to network connectivity
network layer connectivity we also offer
service layer connectivity with private
service connect or psc
psc provides a service-oriented
networking model by abstracting the
underlying network such as peering ip
address configuration etc
psc allows you to create private and
secure connections from your cloud
networks to producer services such as
cloud storage cloud bigtable or
third-party services from elastic
mongodb or snowflake
psc is now ga in all regions and we
introduced three new enhancements
psc with consumer service controls is
now in preview
with https service controls psc allows
customers to have finer grained control
of their own policies and support data
regionalization for sovereign clouds
we added https internal load balancer as
a psc target to help scale services
for example you can configure the load
balancer to log all requests to cloud
logging or choose which services are
available using a url map
psc is integrated with service directory
so you can auto register
available services to make service
consumption even faster and simpler
this is so cool that
companies like bloomberg elastic cloud
and mongodb shared why they are using
private service connect and we hope you
will also test drive psc and let us know
how you like it
now moving up the service stack let's
talk about gke and anthos networking
we released a lot of features in gke and
anthos networking recently and we are
only going to cover four today
first gke gateway controller is google
cloud's implementation of the kubernetes
gateway api and it manages internal and
external https load balancing for a gke
cluster or a fleet of gke clusters
it is currently in preview and well ga
this quarter again cloud dns for gke
supports the full kubernetes dns
specification and eolga discorder
it provides pod and service level
resolution with a fully managed dns that
does not require a cluster hosted dns
provider so it removes the overhead of
managing cluster hosted dns
for bare metal fans out there a bgp
based load balancer for antho spare
metal is now in preview supporting n-way
active active redundancy for faster
failover and efficient utilization
of bandwidth
and lastly with the increasing use of
container network functions or cnfs we
are introducing multi-nic pods on antho
spare metal which allows paws to attach
to multiple network interfaces for use
cases such as data and control plane
separation multi-tenancy
man-management functions etc
now we covered edge hybrid connectivity
service layer networking gke anthony's
networking
what's next
we're going to talk about application
delivery
our application delivery portfolio
offers layer 7 load balancing and layer
4 network load balancing
in the layer 7 load balancing family we
are introducing regional external load
balancer which supports distribution of
http and https traffic to back-ends
hosted on compute engine and gke
our layer 7 load balancers are now
converged on envoy a cncf open source
project
as the common data plane
leveraging envoy proxy the regional
external load balancer provides advanced
traffic management capabilities such as
routing and traffic policies so you can
steer traffic where you want it
in addition we added support for hybrid
load balancing
hybrid load balancing supports workloads
running on-prem
in google cloud or in other clouds to
help customers with migration
performance optimization and high
availability you can use external or
internal https load balancing in
addition to tcp ssl proxy
together
they not only load balance endpoints on
gcp on-prem or other clouds they can
extend cloud armor to provide ddos
protection to your services and leverage
cloud cdn for low latency performance
next let's take a quick look at dns
enhancements now today thousands of
customers use our cloud dns and we've
added a lot of enhancements
one to highlight is cloud dns policy
manager which is in preview
it enables you to steer private and
internet traffic using dynamic responses
from cloud dns
policies may be set up using weight
around robin and or geo location rules
and includes health checks which can be
used for automatic failovers
you can use this to manage traffic in a
multi-vendor environment direct traffic
and set up failover traffic patterns
let's take a look at what's new in
network security
we announced many new
security enhancements this year such as
hierarchical firewall cloud armor rate
limiting and cloud ids
we are excited to announce the preview
of cloud armor bot and fraud management
which leverages recapture enterprise to
detect and stop unwanted bot activity at
the edge of the network
this integrated ddos wav and bot
detection solution uses signals
collected in the browser
plus thread data to automate the
detection of fraud
while customers can use these products
together already we are simplifying the
deployment process and providing a more
integrated experience so customers can
accelerate their time to value
for more information please attend the
session on ddos swap firewalls and
network based threat detection
next we announced cloud ids in july with
our partner palo alto networks cloud ids
provides a fully managed network threat
detection service with high levels of
security efficacy and low noise
we worked closely with palo alto
networks to embed their industry-leading
threat detection technologies and deeply
integrated them into our cloud
beyond having a uniform usage model
across the ui apis and command line
this means that customers can pick from
gcp native targets including anything
from a vpc to a specific workload and
even leverage our flexible tagging
capabilities to identify what they want
to monitor
we surface the alert information in the
google cloud ui apis and cloud logging
systems plus feed the data to our
security command center chronicle and
third-party sim and store products
it's quick and easy to deploy as it is
managed scaled and operated by google
with high performance and availability
all built in
now with all the great products what
about day two ops let's take a look at
monitoring
our flagship monitoring product network
intelligence center has been expanded
with several new modules recently
network topology lets you view actual
flows traffic pattern changes ingress
egress bytes over vpn and interconnect
to and from the internet
and gcp managed services
support for vpns and interconnect is now
in preview and support for google
managed services is now ga
global performance dashboard gives you
real-time metrics such as latency and
packet loss for the google cloud network
as well as visibility into the
performance of your project's resources
with connectivity tests you can check
the connectivity between a vm instance
and gcp managed services such as gke and
cloud sql and troubleshoot issues at any
time
well i hope you enjoy the what's new in
networking session to learn more please
take the time to view the deeper dive
sessions on these topics and visit our
website for more information
thank you for joining us